THIS HEARING FOR THE ASSEMBLY --
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE TODAY IS THE HIGHER
EDUCATION -- PORTION ARE CLOSE
OUT ACTIONS -- FIRST OF ALL
WE'RE GONNA CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HERE BRO [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
CG [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
CORN IS ESTABLISHED.
ALL RIGHT TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON HIGHER AS I SAID WE'RE
DOING TO THE GENERAL FUND ITEMS.
SO WE'RE NOT GONNA BE FOCUSING
ON THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PIECE
IT'LL BE TOMORROW WE HAVE OUR
PROP NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE.
OF COURSE WE HAD A ROBUST --
HEARING SCHEDULE THIS YEAR ON ON
HIGHER AT ISSUES AND ONE OF
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
BUDGET PROPOSALS FROM JANUARY
AND FOR MAY AND AND WITH THAT WE
SEE SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN.
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR OUR UC
AND CSU SYSTEM AS WELL AS
FINANCIAL AID -- NOT A PERFECT
BUDGETS BUT SOMETHING WE CAN ALL
BE PROUD OF ESPECIALLY FOR IT
FOR YOU SEE IN CSU WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT LATER WE'RE ABLE TO
FOCUS ON ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY AND CERTAINLY
CERTAINLY A QUALITY FOR EXISTING
STUDENTS AND WE THINK THIS IS.
WHAT WE HEARD FROM OUR ANALYST?
THE SECOND LARGEST INCREASE IN
IN THE ROD DOLLAR AMOUNT IN THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S ONE YEAR RIGHT AFTER THE
DURING THE DOT COM ERA WE HAD A
LARGER -- DOLLAR AMOUNT INCREASE
SO WE THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW NOT
AS MUCH AS A SYSTEMS ASK FOR BUT
ENOUGH TO REALLY FOCUS ON
INVESTING IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION -- SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS FOCUSING
ON FINANCIAL AID IN THE MAKE
SURE THAT COLLEGE IS MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE NOT
JUST THE TUITION COSTS WHICH
WILL GET.
TO IN A BIT SO CERTAINLY --
PLEASED ABOUT THE PACKAGE WE
HAVE HERE TODAY -- SO WITH THAT
BEFORE WE GET TO THE MAJOR ITEMS
WE'RE GOING TO DO A VOTE ONLY.
ON SOME OF THESE ITEMS THAT WERE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S -- NAY REVISED.
AND APRIL FINANCE LETTERS SO
THOSE WOULD BE ISSUES THE VOTE
ONLY SECTION ISSUES ONE THROUGH.
TWENTY SEVEN LOOKING FOR A
MOTION ON THAT PACKAGE.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
THE END -- UNDERSTAND THAT MAYBE
SOME.
OF THE REPUBLICANS MAY WANT TO
CALL SOME OUT YOU'RE NOT VOTING
ON THAT ACCURATE.
THIS IS A PIECE OF THE UC STUFF
SO THIS IS THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
THESE ARE ISSUES ONE THROUGH.
TWENTY SEVEN SO NOT THE UC
PACKAGE BUT THERE ARE.
A FEW UC ITEMS THERE.
WELL WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
FOR THE WHOLE PACKAGE AND WE'RE
GONNA CALL THE ROLL BUT IF YOU
WANNA CALL OUT ONES THAT YOU
WANT -- TO NOT VOTE ON OR VOTE
NO ON YOUR FREE TO DO SO AT THIS
POINT.
OR WE CAN DO IS WE CAN DO
LOOKING VOTE ON IT.
AND THEN AFTERWARDS YOU CAN
COMMENT AND CLARIFY.
WHICH ONES YOU WANT TO BE
ADJUSTED FOR WE CAN DO THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND ON THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
ISSUES ONE THROUGH TWENTY SEVEN
THIS IS -- FOR PR STATE LIBRARY --
WILL TO YOU SEE HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF LAW CSU ESTIMATE COMMISSION.
NOW PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HI.
BRO [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
I WAS [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
OKAY NOW WE HAVE THE UC PACKAGE
AND AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE PLEASED
THAT WHERE -- PROVIDING SOME
SIGNIFICANT ON GOING FUNDING FOR
THE UC AS PROPOSED BY -- THE
GOVERNOR AND AGAIN IF YOU WANT
TO FOLLOW ALONG THIS IS ON PAGE.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN SO OUR
PROPOSAL IS -- WE APPROVE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- AB TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THREE AND A HALF
MILLION FOR USE THE ON GOING AND
THAT ACTUALLY AT TWO MILLION
MORE -- ONE OF THINGS WE DO IS --
WE REJECT THE PROPOSAL FOCUSING
ON ACADEMIC QUALITY WILL ACT IN
THE CALL IS IMPORTANT.
WE WEREN'T CONVINCED OF THE
PROPOSAL NORTH THAT THAT THE
ACTUAL NEED WE COMPARED TO OTHER --
PRIORITIES -- FOR YOU SEE WHICH
WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT SUCH AS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THE ISSUE THAT
WE HERE AT HOME MOST ABOUT IS
HOW ARE CONSTITUENTS AND GET
INTO THE GREAT UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE WE'RE GONNA
RE DIRECT -- THAT MONEY TO
ENROLL TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MORE
UNDERGRADUATES.
AND ONE THOUSAND MORE A GRADUATE
STUDENT SO.
THAT CERTAINLY WILL HELP OUR OUR
STUDENTS WHO ARE.
MORE AND MORE ELIGIBLE AND READY
TO GO TO THE UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA --
WE ALSO -- ARE PROVIDING ABOVE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET NINETY
FIVE MILLION AND ONE TIME THIS
IS SOMEWHAT DISCRETIONARY MONEY
FOR THE UC I KNOW THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE HOPE THIS WAS ON
GOING BUT YOU KNOW ALL WE HAVE
IN THIS.
THE ARCHITECTURE THE BUDGET IS
ONE TIME RESOURCES SO YOU KNOW
THAT I THINK WILL CERTAINLY HELP
YOU SEE DEAL WITH THEIR ISSUES
AND SO THE OVERALL -- BUDGET FOR
THE UC ONE TIME IS TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE MILLION A COUPLE
OTHER ISSUES I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
ARE ON A DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
ISSUES IN SEISMIC WE KNOW THAT
SAID A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE AT ALL
OF THE THE NINE YOU SEE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES PLUS THE
TENTH OF UC SAN FRANCISCO -- ONE
THING WE ARE ADDING THIS YEAR IS
WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING WITH SOME
CAMPUSES AND SOME --
PHILANTHROPY ACROSS THE STATE TO
PROVIDE A NEW EFFORT FOR SEISMIC
TO ALLOW.
MORE MONEY TO GO TO CAMPUS IS ON
A MATCHING BASIS SO IF
INDIVIDUALS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
CAN PROVIDE MONEY FOR THIS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE
THINK WILL.
ALLOW US TO STRETCH THE SCARCE
DOLLARS AGAIN OUR BIGGEST --
BANG FOR THE BUCK TO DEAL WITH
OUR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND AND
SEISMIC NEEDS AND THEN LASTLY.
WE'RE GOING -- TO CAN FORM WITH
THE SENATE ACTION RELATED -- TO
CALIFORNIAN ROMANS AND NON
RESIDENTS ENROLLMENTS --
THROUGHOUT THE EAST UC SYSTEM'S
BEEN UP CERTAINLY A HOT ISSUE.
WITHIN THE STATE CAPITOL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
AND CONVERSELY MORE SOMETIMES WE
GET MORE AND MORE ACCESS FOR NON
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND SO.
WE'RE COMMITTING COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU SEE TO ENSURE
THIS -- REDUCTION DOESN'T
FINANCIALLY HARM THE CAMPUSES SO
THIS IS.
A A MULTI YEAR PLAN --
PREDICATED ON OF COURSE MONEY IN
EACH BUDGET YEAR BUT WITH THAT
WE WILL BE LOOKING TO BEGAN
HAVING A TENYEAR REDUCTION IN
NON.
RESIDENT ENROLLMENT STARTING
NEXT YEAR.
SO WITH THAT THAT'S A A SUMMARY
OF THE UC PACKAGE AND WE HAVE
SOME COMMENTS FROM MISTER --
MEDINA THE MISTER MURATSUCHI
MISTER GALLAGHER.
SO ON ON THE FLOOR YESTERDAY --
AS UCLA CELEBRATED ITS ONE
HUNDREDTH BIRTHDAY -- ONE
HUNDRED YEARS OF UCLA BEING IN
EXISTENCE WE HEARD FROM MANY
MEMBERS.
OF HOW PROUD THEY ARE OF UCLA
AND THE GREAT WORK THE GREAT
UNIVERSITY THAT UCLA IS.
AND NOT BEING AT UCLA GRAD
MYSELF.
I I I THINK THE SAME CAN BE SAID.
FOR ALL THE UC CAMPUSES I I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT ANYONE IS ANY --
YOU KNOW I THINK THEY'RE ALL
EQUAL AND AND EXCELLENCE ALL OF
THEM ALL TEN UC CAMPUSES SO AS
WE HEARD THAT.
ON THE FLOOR YESTERDAY -- WE
HEARD AN OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT.
OF FROM MEMBERS ON ON HOW
IMPORTANT YOU SEE IS TO
CALIFORNIA AND HOW PROUD.
WE ARE OF OUR UC SYSTEM.
SO I AM HAPPY THAT WE HAVE THE
NINETY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME AS
THE CHAIR SAID.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO IT BECOMING
ON GOING IN THE YEARS TO COME
AND I WILL BE -- ADVOCATING FOR
THAT IN IN IN THE YEAR NEXT YEAR
AS WELL SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN MAKE
THAT NINETY FIVE MILLION -- ON
GOING.
THE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YES SIR MR MY TEACHING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I JOIN THE THE CHAIR
OF A THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND AND BEING PROUD OF
OUR UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
AND I YOU KNOW.
BELIEVE THAT -- THAT -- OUR
UNIVERSITIES -- ARE ARE CAN'T UC
CAMPUSES ARE AMONG THE THE BEST --
CONSISTENTLY RANK AMONG THE BEST
IN THE COUNTRY -- IN A WITH
MULTIPLE CAMPUSES ARE ON THOSE
LISTS OF THE BEST PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES IN THE COUNTRY AND
AND WE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WE MAINTAIN THAT.
I I WOULD LIKE [inaudible]
TO RESPECTFULLY -- PUT A
DIFFERENT SPIN AND THEN THE THAN
THE SUB COMMITTEE CHAIR IN IN IN
IN TERMS OF THE INVESTMENT --
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
ARM YOU KNOW WE ARE PROVIDING A
RECORD AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
OUR GENERAL FUND BUDGET IS AT A
RECORD HIGH.
AND BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
PROPORTION OF OUR GENERAL FUND --
THAT IS GOING TO SUPPORT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA -- IT NOT
ONLY IS IT NOT WHAT -- IT HAS
BEEN BEFORE OUR LAST TWO
RECESSIONS BUT AS WE DISCUSSED
AT OUR LAST -- BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING -- ARE.
THE STE STATE CONTRIBUTION TO
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA CORE
FUNDS HAS DROPPED FROM ABOUT 70%.
TO NOW ABOUT 40%.
THEN AND WHAT I'M CONCERNED IS
THAT YOUR NUMBER.
ONE THE IT.
I NOW THAT.
AS A CHERRY -- TALKED ABOUT THE
ARCHITECTURE OF THE BUDGET IS IS
IS ALL COMING TOGETHER.
YOU KNOW.
WITH WHEN WE LOOK AT THE BIG
PICTURE OF OF OUR OVERALL BUDGET
IN COMING TOGETHER THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
ASK WAS.
RELATIVELY MODEST THEY WERE
ASKING -- FOR NOT ONLY THE THE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT AN
ADDITIONAL -- INVESTMENT OF A
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS -- AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE OVERALL -- BUDGET SURPLUS
THIS YEAR OF TWENTY ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
IN -- A HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS I I FIND IT.
YOU KNOW DISAPPOINTED THAT WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO COME UP WITH
THAT ADDITIONAL -- HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS -- I
I JUST THINK IT'S JUST A
REMINDER TO ALL OF US THAT.
THAT AS WE'RE WE'RE GOING
FORWARD -- ESPECIALLY IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT A POTENTIAL --
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN SOMETIME IN
THE NEXT. THREE TO FIVE YEARS --
IF WE'RE LUCKY -- IF NOT SOONER --
YOU WHERE WHERE WHERE AND AS
WERE TAKING ON NEW -- GENERAL
FUND OBLIGATIONS -- THROUGH SOME
OF THE NEW PRIORITIES THAT --
THIS GOVERNOR AND AND ARE
LEGISLATURE IS IS LOOKING AT
WE'RE SETTING OURSELVES UP AT IT
ONCE AGAIN FOR ANOTHER ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN -- WERE PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION IS YOU KNOW BIG
BECAUSE PUBLIC IRISH EDUCATION
IS NOT.
PROTECTED IN THE FUN THROUGH --
MECHANISM LIKE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT THAT THAT WE'RE
SETTING OURSELVES UP FOR YOU --
YET ANOTHER DISPROPORTIONATE --
IMPACT ON PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION THE FACT THAT WE COULD
NOT RESTORE MORE -- DURING THESE
GOOD BUDGET YEARS -- AS A
DISAPPOINTMENT TO ME -- SO.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING TODAY'S
BUDGET RELUCTANTLY -- BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK -- DOWN
THE LINE IN TERMS OF HOW TO HOW
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE --
YOU KNOW WALKING THE TALK WHEN
WE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT FULLY
FUNDING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NOT FULLY
FUNDED THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE WERE FAR FROM.
WHERE WE USED TO BE WHERE WE
SHOULD BE -- AND AND SO MISTER
CHAIR I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU TO A TO CONTINUE --
TOWARD THIS EFFORT.
THANK YOU.
YEAH MR GALLAGHER YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS OVER UC'S BUDGET --
IN THE IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS THIS YEAR AND I AND I
THINK THERE'S A LOT THE THAT WE
AGREE ON AND I THINK THAT.
IN THIS IN THIS PACKAGE WE'VE --
WE'VE BROUGHT TOGETHER A LOT OF
THINGS THAT I THINK WE WANT TO
HELP -- ONE HELP STEER INDIRECT.
OF THE FUTURE OF OF YOU SEE --
IN IN A WAY THAT THAT I THINK.
MOST OF US AGREE IS MORE
RESPONSIBLE -- YOU KNOW WHERE I
WHERE I DIVERT A LITTLE BIT AND
I'LL I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT -- IS LOOK I'M A VERY
PROUD UC GRADUATE MYSELF -- AND
I'M PROUD OF THAT UNIVERSITY IN
BECAUSE I'M PROUD OF THAT SYSTEM --
I CANNOT CAN ALLOW IT TO
CONTINUE TO RUN THE WAY THAT IT
IS.
I CANNOT ALLOW THE STATUS QUO.
OF HOW THAT UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IS
BEING OPERATED TO CONTINUE.
AND SO FOR ONE I'M GOING TO
DIVERGE FROM CONTINUING THIS
THIS GAME OF APPROVING
ENROLLMENT NUMBERS ONLY GET NO
DATA -- JUST BASICALLY RIGHT IN
A BLANK CHECK ON ENROLLMENT
NUMBERS -- IN THE UC SYSTEM.
WITHOUT BEING PROVIDED ANY ANY
REAL HARD DATA AS TO HOW MANY
PEOPLE THEY INTEND TO ENROLL IN
A GIVEN YEAR.
AND WHEN WE STILL DON'T REALLY
HAVE STRONG ASSURANCES THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET.
THE AMOUNT OF IN STATE STUDENTS.
ENROLLED IN OUR UC SYSTEM WHICH
WAS THE GOAL OF THE MASTER PLAN --
BUT THE OTHER GOAL THE MASTER
PLAN WAS NOT TO MAKE YOU SEE.
THE BIG ENROLLMENT -- THAT
UNIVERSITY AND I THINK A LOT OF
THAT MONEY IS BETTER SPENT.
ON OUR CSU SYSTEM WHOSE ACTUALLY
BEING RESPONSIVE TO US IN THIS
OF FAT IN THIS AFFECT.
WHOSE ACTUALLY ENSURING THAT WE
ARE GIVING OPPORTUNITIES. TO
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND PROVIDING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES.
MUCH BETTER THAN THE UC SYSTEM
IS RIGHT NOW -- SO I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING -- THESE MEASURES THE
CONTINUOUS DOWN THAT PATH OF
JUST KIND OF OPENING UP THE THE
ENROLLMENT -- FUNDING FOR THE UC
[inaudible]
I THINK.
ON THE MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING I
BELIEVE THIS IS A GOOD STEP WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS
EVENTUALLY DO IS NOT DO THIS
PIECEMEAL AND SORT OF PARTNER
WITH.
COUNTY -- K. THROUGH TWELVE
ANOTHER HIGHER ED PROGRAMS. TO
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE MENTAL
HEALTH -- PROGRAM -- SO I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE US MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION AT SOME POINT -- I
THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW WE'RE
DOING SOME GOOD THINGS IN TERMS
OF CAL GRANTS -- THE OTHER.
ISSUE THAT I WANTED.
TO POINT OUT IS AYE AYE.
I THINK IT'S GOOD THAT WERE
REJECTING THE THE FIFTY MILLION
THAT WAS DIRECTED TOWARDS FOR
YOUR GRADUATION RATES -- I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE US GET SOME MORE
DETAIL ON TO WHAT THAT NINETY
FIVE MILLION.
THAT WE'RE GONNA RE DIRECT IS
GOING INTO -- IN A HOLE FOR
THAT'LL GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
FOR THEIR FRESH FLESHED OUT AS
WE MOVE.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS --
BUT I THINK PUTTING IT ALL INTO
A ROOM AND IS IS IS NOT
NECESSARILY RIGHT -- FIX
CERTAINLY WERE WE ARE DOING SOME
THINGS TO TO ADDRESS FACILITIES
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT TO ME
IS A VERY BIG ISSUE THAT YOU SEE
RIGHT NOW.
IS ENSURING THAT YOU HAVE THE
FACILITIES.
LONG TERM.
THAT ARE MAINTAINED AND THAT WE
HAVE IN THAT WE HAVE SERVICES
FOR THE STUDENTS.
THAT INCLUDES MENTAL HEALTH THAT
INCLUDES HEALTH -- AND IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE NOT EVEN DOING WHAT
WE NEED TO DO FOR THE STUDENTS
WHO ATTEND YOU SEE RIGHT NOW.
AND YET WE'RE SAYING HEY GO AND
YOU KNOW LET'S READ A BLANK
CHECK TO ENROLL MORE STUDENTS --
THERE'S SOME GOOD THINGS IN HERE
THE SEISMIC RETROFIT MONEY
SEISMIC RETROFIT MONEY I THINK
IS IS VITAL FOR MANY OF THE UC
CAMPUSES. TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
SAFE AND OTHER FACILITIES ARE
GOING TO BE.
IN GOOD SHAPE LONG TERM -- SO I
THINK THAT'S POSITIVE -- THEN
YOU KNOW I DO LIKE THE LANGUAGE
ENSURING THAT WE GET TO REDUCE
NON RESIDENT ROMA 210% -- BUT
CERTAINLY -- YOU KNOW.
I KNOW WE NEED TO SEE SOME
RESPONSIVENESS OF THE UC SYSTEM
BETTER RESPONSIVENESS AND I
THINK.
WE HAVE SEEN SO I THINK WE'RE
DOING MANY THINGS THAT WE ALL
AGREE.
NEED TO BE DONE TO TO MOVE THE
YOU SEE IN A BETTER DIRECTION --
I THINK I THINK WHAT WE ALSO DID
HERE IS WE REJECTED THIS YOU
KNOW THIS OUT RIGHT.
HEY PLEASE JUST PAY FOR ALL OF
OUR SALARY INCREASES -- WITH
BASICALLY NO DISCRETION
WHATSOEVER -- WE REJECTED THAT
PROPOSAL I THINK IN ESSENCE BY
NOT PROVIDING THAT FULL LAST
AMOUNT -- FOR ME SEE -- AND WE
PUT AND WE'RE PUTTING THE MONEY
INTO PLACES WHERE WE KNOW IT IS
NEEDED FACILITIES -- EXCEPT HER
SO.
WITH THAT BEING SAID YOU KNOW
I'M IN A SUPPORT MANY OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH WITH A FEW
THAT I WILL BE.
VOTING NO ON THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN CLEAR ENOUGH.
THANK YOU -- DO BEFORE WE TAKE
THAT THE VOTE HERE JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT A FEW THAT WERE
TOUCHED UPON THE AND REALLY
HIGHLIGHT -- TOO MUCH.
IS WE HEARD.
NOT JUST THE OVERALL IN ROMAN
AND QUALITY ISSUES BUT SO MUCH
NOW WITH STUDENTS THAT THE THE
BASIC NEEDS.
DEALING WITH -- RAPPER HOUSING
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING OF TWO FIVE FIND A
PLACE TO SLEEP OTHER GOING TO
SCHOOL STUDENT HUNGER -- MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES SO -- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THINK THAT WE'RE
WORKING TO ADDRESS AND A SMART
WAY HERE.
AND WITH THAT I KNOW THAT YOU
SAID MR DOLLAR TO BE HAVING SOME
COORDINATION WITH OTHER PROGRAMS
AND ONE THING THAT WE DID HERE
WHICH I THINK IS VERY POSITIVE
AS WE TOOK SOME MONEY OFF THE
TOP.
OF THE PROP SIXTY THREE MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM RECOGNIZING THAT
COLLEGE MENTAL HEALTH STOOD
MENTAL HEALTH IS THE KEY SUCCESS.
FOR COLLEGE SUCCESS AND SO WE
HAVE THAT NOT JUST FOR YOU SEE
BUT FOR CSU.
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SO.
THE FEAR FOR TAKE A VOTE THIS IS
IN A A PERFECT YOU SEE BUDGET
FOR THE ADVOCATES BUT I WILL SAY.
IS BETTER THAN THE SENATE
VERSION AS BETTER IN THE
GOVERNOR'S VERSION SO WE ARE
LEADING THE WAY IN INVESTING IN
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SO.
REMEMBER THAT.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO ARE VERY
DISAPPOINTED TODAY --
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES -- CHILD
CARE HEALTH CARE ADVOCATES ARE
SOMETIMES GETTING THE BIG GOOSE
EGG ON THEIR REQUEST IN THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR.
SO FOR THOSE WHO WHO WHO SAY
THAT WE COULD BE DOING MORE
THAT'S TRUE BUT I THINK WE NEED.
TO KEEP IN PERSPECTIVE AND YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO GO NOW SO VOTERS
WHAT THEY WANT TO PAY FOR
EDUCATION TO THEY WANT TO BE.
FORTY FIRST IN THE NATION AND
FOR PEOPLE FUNDING THEY WANT TO
HAVE OUR OUR HIGHER ED SYSTEM.
THAT'S THAT'S LAGGING BEHIND US
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY AND SO
YOU KNOW ABSENT SHUTTING DOWN
ALL TEN STATE PRISONS ARE
SHUTTING DOWN OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AND AND CLOSING ALL CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS AND PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS IN.
DIFFERING THOSE FUNDS OVER HERE --
I DON'T SEE THOSE PROPOSALS
BEFORE US TODAY SO WE HAVE TO
LIVE WITHIN OUR MEANS AND SO --
THAT'S A WERE -- VOTING ON THIS
AFTERNOON OR THIS MORNING.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
IS SECONDS AND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
TAKES.
OKAY SEC -- DID YOU WANT TO
BEFORE WE CALL THE ROLL.
DID YOU WANT TO TAKE SOME OF
THOSE ITEMS OUT RIGHT NOW --
AFTER THE FACT MISTER GALLAGHER
MISTER BROWN.
YOU CAN YOU CAN COME IN CHANGE
AFTER WE TAKE THESE ACTIONS IF
THAT'S EASIER FOR YOU
[inaudible]
EXCUSE ME [inaudible]
ALL THIS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
SO -- ONCE YOU LIST THOSE OUT
NOW.
ALL RIGHT SO I WILL BE VOTING NO
ON ITEMS [inaudible] THREE NINE
AND THIRTEEN GET.
THE SERVER THEN I WROTE
EVERYTHING UNDER THE SAME.
THERE'S A CHERUB I'M AND I WOULD
EXCEPT FOR I'M A NO ON EIGHT
ELEVEN TWELVE STAINING ON
THIRTEEN NO ON UNDER THE STUDENT
AID NO ON WE DO WE TAKE THAT UP
AT THE STUDENT YET.
HOW ABOUT WE JUST DO THIS LET'S
JUST TAKE?
A A MOTION ON THE WHOLE PACKAGE
AND THEN IT WILL ALLOW YOU TO
STAY.
TO JUST TELL THE STAFF WHICH
ONES YOU DON'T BE RECORD AS AN
EYE ON SO MOTION ON THE WHOLE
YOU SEE PACKAGE.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
OVER HERE.
MOST IN A SECOND MISTER
MURATSUCHI MISTER MEDINA
[inaudible]
MCCARTY HI [inaudible]
BRO.
MR UELMEN TO JUST SAY I HIGH
WITH INDIVIDUAL THE CHANNELS DO
THAT AFTERWARDS [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
HI WITH MY PREVIOUS BILL CHANGES
[inaudible]
MEDINA.
WE'RE SEARCHING AYE O'DONNELL.
AND JUST FOR THE RECORD AGAIN
CALL UP THE ONES YOU DON'T WANT
TO BE RECORDED AND I ON MISTER
BROWN -- I'LL BE A NO ON EIGHT
ELEVEN TWELVE STATING ON
THIRTEEN AND ON THE STUDENT AID
BUDGET PACKAGE -- BE A NO ON
FORGET WE'RE GETTING THERE AND
IT JUST IT JUST YOU SEE RIGHT
NOW. 811-12 NO OF STATE ON
THIRTY OKAY MR GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
NOW ON NO. ONE THREE NINE AND
THIRTEEN OKAY [inaudible]
PERFECT.
WE GOT THAT DONE.
AND I KNOW WE NEED TO GO BACK
AND ON THE VOTE ONLY ONCE
ADDRESS.
MR BROWN MR GALLAGHER'S CHANGES
THERE.
TOO SO WITH THAT LET'S PROCEED
WITH THE CSU.
BUDGET PACKAGE.
AND WE WILL BE APPROVING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
PLUSES MAY REVISE CHANGES.
PLUS -- A LITTLE BIT MORE IN ONE
TIME AND ON GOING MONEY FOR THE
CSU -- WE'RE PROVIDING CSU WITH
A TOTAL OF SIX HUNDRED MILLION.
AND IN NEW A GENERAL FUND --
ROUGHLY HALF IS ONGOING HALF OF
COURSE IS IS ONE TIME.
THIS WILL PROVIDE UP TO SEVEN
THOUSAND MORE SLOTS FOR
CALIFORNIA KIDS TO GO TO THE CSU
SYSTEM.
AND WILL USE OF COMBINATION OF
ON GOING IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
FULLY SUPPORT THE GRAD
INITIATIVE WHICH HELP STUDENT
GRADUATE WITHOUT LESS DEBT.
AND ALSO -- ADDRESSES ACCESS BY
HAVING STUDENTS -- YOU KNOW
LEAVE THE CSU SYSTEM AND MAKING
A SEATS AVAILABLE FOR CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS HOW WE ALSO
FULLY FRIEND FULLY FUND THE
PROJECT REBOUND PROGRAM.
AS SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THE GOING
TO EXPAND TO OTHER CAMPUSES
HELPING RE INTEGRATE -- THOSE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED HIGHER
EDUCATION.
WE ALSO ASKED CSU TO SET ASIDE
SOME OF THE MONEY OVER THE OFF
THE TOP TO INCREASE A TENURE
TRACK FACULTY WHICH WE THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
TO STUDENT SUCCESS IN GRADUATION.
RATES AS WELL AS WHAT WE DID
WITH THE UC WE ARE STEERING SOME
PROP SIXTY THREE MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDS TO HELP INCREASE.
AND IMPROVE STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AND WITH THAT OPEN TO ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
ESTHER MEDINA.
ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE -- FOR PUTTING IN THE
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR PROJECT
REBOUND.
I THINK THEY HAVE DEMONSTRATED
WHAT A VALUABLE AND SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM IT IS.
AND JUST VERY HAPPY TO SEE THAT
WE PUT IN THE BUDGET TO FULLY
FUND AND LET THEM -- EXPAND THE
PROGRAM [inaudible]
OKAY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER.
GROWN A SECOND FROM MISTER.
O'DONNELL -- WE WANT TO MAKE --
ONE ADJUSTMENT HERE.
IT'S NOT IN THE AGENDA WE WANT
TO ADD TO THE CSU BUDGET.
MR DONALD THREE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME TO FIND THE CSU -- CSU.
FIRST CENTER -- TO TO TO ADD
CENTER CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
THE IDEA WOULD BE THAT WE FIND
ONE PLACE TO THE UC ONE STOP
SHOP WHERE THEY GATHER THE BEST
PRACTICES ASSOCIATED.
WITH CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND THEN AND VIEWS THOSE INTO --
OUR TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT SPECIFIC TO THE
CSU WELL AGAIN WITH A FOCUS.
ON CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT CAM
OKAY FOR THE CSU CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP CENTER.
THEY'LL BE A THREE MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME -- ADDITION TO
THE BUDGET BEFORE US TODAY SO WE
HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND ON THE CSU PACKAGE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
MCCARTY I BRO [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
LIMóN [inaudible]
DINA [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
I OKAY AND DO WE HAVE ANY.
CHANGES TO THAT MR BRELO MISTER
GALLAGHER.
CSU PACKAGE OKAY GREAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALMOST DONE.
ALL RIGHT FINALLY RE GOING TO
ADDRESS.
OUR FINANCIAL AID.
IS RELATED TO THE CALIFORNIA'S
TO NEED COMMISSION -- WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT MORE --
FINANCIALLY THROUGH THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM WE WENT -- TO TO
SLIGHTLY -- TWEAK THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL RELATED -- TO FINANCIAL
AID AND PUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
MONEY -- FROM THE GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT ACCESS TO TO COLLEGE
AND WE KNOW THROUGH OUR ROBUST.
HEARINGS THISYEAR WE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ON COLLEGE ISN'T
JUST ABOUT TUITION ANYMORE IT'S
ABOUT BOOKS AND TRANSPORTATION
AND HOUSING AND FOOD.
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO TO ADDRESS
THAT WITH OUR FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM WE ALSO KNOW THE DATE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
IS NOT A PERFECT ONE IT'S WAS
ONE OF THE NBA'S ACROSS THE
NATION'S RISE FINANCIAL AID BUT
WE LEAVE TOO MANY STUDENTS.
A BEHIND ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
ARE APPLYING FOR THE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS THOSE WHO.
APPLY A YEAR TO AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL AND ARE NO LONGER
ELIGIBLE FOR THE ENTITLEMENT AND
ROUGHLY ONE IN FIFTEEN OR SO
STUDENTS TO APPLY FOR THAT
ACTUALLY GET THE AWARDS WE THINK
THAT SAID.
AN INJUSTICE FOR PEOPLE TRYING
TO GET A HIGHER EDUCATION SO
WE'RE LOOKING TO DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVE -- SUCCESS OF THE CAL
GRANT COMPETITIVE PROGRAM SO
WE'LL BE WE'LL BE FOCUSED ON
APPROVING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE ROUGHLY
FIVE THOUSAND WORDS.
AND ADD ON ANOTHER FORTY
THOUSAND ABOVE THAT THAT'S OUR
SIGNATURE INVESTMENT IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR FINANCE LATE
FOR THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM CELEB
A TOTAL OF SEVENTY THOUSAND
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT TO WORDS.
WE ALSO HEARD A LOUD AND CLEAR
FROM OUR UC AND CSU STUDENTS
ABOUT.
FINANCIAL AID DURING THE SUMMER
CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS I WANT TO
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY -- SUMMER SCHOOLS
MORE EXPENSIVE ANYONE TO BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE THOSE CAL GRANTS IN
THE SUMMER.
BUT THAT IMPACTS THEIR THE
LIFELINE OF THE CAL fNTS
RATHER FOR YEARS AND SO WILL BE.
FOCUSING ON A NEW A SUMMER CAL
GRANT PROPOSAL AT SEVEN POINT
FOUR MILLION THIS YEAR GROWS TO
ABOUT TEN MILLION IN THE OUT
YEARS -- ALSO A FOCUS ON A FEW
OTHER -- FINANCIAL AID --
PROGRAMS THAT CAL GRANT BE
STUDENT CENTER BRENT PROGRAM TO
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY CAN
PARTICIPATE.
IN OUR STATE WORK CITY LIKE
PROGRAMS -- WHERE WE'RE MAKING A
CHANGE AS FAR AS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED SOME FINANCIAL AID OUT
REACH INTO STE? TWO IMPORTANT
REGIONS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE IN
CENTRAL VALLEY WEDDING IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE WANT.
TO HAVE THE CAL SO PROGRAM FOCUS
ON THAT AS OPPOSED TO CREATING A
NEW PROGRAM.
AS FAR AS THE TEACHERS TEACHER
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS KIND OF A
K. TWELVE ISSUE BUT IT'S ENOUGH
FINANCIAL AID BUDGET TO BE --
SUPPORT THE NOTION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S THAT FOCUSED ON IN
INCREASING RESOURCES FOR OUR
TEACHER SHORTAGE TO FOCUS ON
GETTING TEACHERS IN THAT FIELD
BUT ALSO.
TEACHING IN THE CLASSROOMS THAT
ARE MOST IN NEED HOWEVER GOING
TO SWAP OUT THE IDEA AND HAVE IT
GO THROUGH THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER PROGRAM AS OPPOSED.
TO THE TEACHER SERVICE CREDIT
PROGRAM AND THEN LASTLY -- WE
ARE SUPPORTERS ONCE AGAIN OF THE
CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNTS THE
KINDERGARTEN TO COLLEGE --
EFFORTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE GOING TO SWAP OUT FROM
THE FIRST FIVE STATE FIRST FIVE
COMMISSION TO HAVE THIS DEBATE
COMMISSION ADMINISTER THESE --
THESE PROGRAMS AND SO YOU KNOW
THIS IS AN EFFORT THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO TO MAKE COLLEGE
MORE AFFORDABLE AND HOPEFULLY
MAKE IT MORE.
AT DEBT FREE FOR CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE STARTING THIS YEAR AND
HOPEFULLY IN A MULTI YEAR PATH
MISTER MEDINA TO MAKE --
FINANCIAL AID WORK BETTER FOR
THE THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE STUDENTS SO -- CERTAINLY
PROUD OF OUR FINANCIAL AID --
PACKAGE YOU TODAY WHICH WILL
HELP COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
TREMENDOUSLY AS WELL AS UC AND
CSU STUDENTS SO.
I WITH THAT ENTERTAIN ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AS WELL AS
A MOTION AND SECOND [inaudible]
MOVIE I OKAY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
GALLAGHER.
I MEAN JUST REALLY BRIEFLY I
THINK WE'RE DOING SOME GOOD
THINGS HERE AT THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM MAKING IT STRONGER --
JUST KIND OF LINKING BACK.
TO SOME OF THINGS I WAS TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER I I FEEL LIKE IF
WE COULD DO.
SOME MORE GET THINGS WITH CAL
GRANTS AND MAYBE EVEN RE DIRECT
FUNDING -- FROM OTHER AREAS WE
COULD ACTUALLY HELP WITH MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT STUDENTS ARE
FACING WHETHER IT'S HOUSING
ISSUES WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY FOOD AND AND UNGER
ISSUES.
ECCENTRICITY I LIKE WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN TERMS OF THE THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM -- I'D LIKE TO SEE
IS MAYBE EVEN.
FIND WAYS WE COULD WOULD BEEF
THAT UP EVEN BETTER -- BUT YOU
KNOW I THINK A LOT OF THESE
CHANGES ARE ARE ARE POSITIVE SO
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU I I DID WANT TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
NOW WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
JUST ONE CLARIFICATION HERE AS
FAR AS THE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S --
EFFORTS TO TALK ABOUT THE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
ARE ALSO PARENTS.
AND WE OF COURSE REDIRECT THAT
TO THE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM WE ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE ISSUE THAT THE
GOVERNOR RAISING THE PROPOSAL SO
WHEN WE INCREASE THESE --
COMPETITIVE AWARDS WE WANT.
TO GIVE -- RECOGNITION AND ADD
ON A SCORING SYSTEM THE FOCUS ON
COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT OUR
PARENTS AND SO WILL BE --
ADOPTING -- PROVING INTENT
TRAILER LANGUAGE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TODAY THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF POINTS
STUDENTS RECEIVE WHO ARE PARENTS
TO HELP THEM -- SUCCEED MORE IN
COLLEGE THROUGH OUR CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HI BRO.
I ACCEPT THE NO ONE FOUR FIVE
SIX AND EIGHT GALLAGHER.
BY WITH THE NO ON FOR IN
[inaudible]
SIX LIMóN.
MEDINA ALL RIGHT WE'RE SEARCHING
HI.
BUT ON OKAY THAT MEASURE PASSES
WE RECORD THE ABSTENTIONS ON THE
FINANCIALLY PIECE FOR MISTER
GALLAGHER MISTER BRO.
SO THAT -- CONCLUDES TODAY'S
ACTION WE WILL COME BACK
TOMORROW WITH OUR PROP.
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE WITH K..
TWELVE REALLY EDUCATION AS WELL
AS OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SO --
MISTER GALLAGHER MISTER BRO WENT --
TO FOCUS ON THAT CHANGING SOME
VOTES ON THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
THERE AND THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.
YES THEY DELIVER CHANGED YEAH
OKAY SO -- HIGHER EDUCATION
GENERAL FUND [inaudible]
ITEM -- THE STAIN ON ISSUE FOR
STAYING ON ISSUE SIX NO ON ISSUE
NINE NO ONE ISSUE TEN NO INITIAL
ELEVEN NO ARE YOU CAN YOU.
CAN YOU SLOW DOWN TO OUR REPAIR
START AGAIN NOT.
NOT VOTING ON FOR SIX NO.
ONE NINE NO ON TEN NO.
ONE ELEVEN NO.
ONE SIXTEEN NO [inaudible]
ONE NINETEEN BUT SAID.
AND YOU GOT THE OTHER%
[inaudible]
TWO YEAH YEAH.
OKAY MISTER GALLAGHER.
OKAY OF WATER WHILE WAITING FOR
MISTER GALLAGHER WE CAN DO TO
ADD ONS FOR SOME WOMEN REALLY
MONTH.
OKAY THANK YOU.
LIMON VOTE ONLY ITEMS ONE
THROUGH.
TWENTY SEVEN YOU SEE BUDGET
PACKAGE LEóN [inaudible]
THE NEWS [inaudible]
ALRIGHT
.
MAKE SURE THE CELTICS.
THAT'S THE BIG MONEY. TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS NOT YESTERDAY
WHEN WE LEARNED. ONE THING
[inaudible]
PENSION.
YEAH YEAH YEAH WHAT TIME.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TEN BILLION
DOLLARS [inaudible]
EXACTLY [inaudible]
THAT'S YEAH SB DRESSED PEOPLE
GOING [inaudible]
FOR NEW PLACE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THE MAIN.
ALL I THINK ONE OF THE GREATEST.
YEAH BUT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
[inaudible]
SCHOOL DISTRICT
YEAH YEAH
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
YES -- YEAH -- MR GALLAGHER
[inaudible] FIVE MAIL ON
NINE
ELEVEN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN NINETY
THAT'S IT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE
CLARIFICATION.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN
WE'LL HAVE THESE ACTION ITEMS AS
WELL POSTED ON THE ASSEMBLY.
BUDGET COMMITTEE WEBSITE --
LATER TODAY THANK YOU